لقد قرأت أنك قلت إنني أعتقد حقًا
أن الكاميرا ستكون لوحة المفاتيح التالية ،
ما الذي قصدته بذلك ، لذلك
أتذكر عندما بدأ الناس في استخدام أجهزة الكمبيوتر لأول مرة ،
استخدمنا الاستعارات المادية
لتمثيل الأشياء ، كان هناك
رمز مهملات صغير وأيقونة مجلد صغيرة  ثم
انتقلت من لوحات المفاتيح والماوس إلى اللمس ،
الأمر الذي يبدو أكثر سهولة ، مثل
أن لدي أطفالًا صغارًا وهم دائمًا ما
يلامسون التلفاز على أمل أن
يستجيب لك مؤخرًا صوتًا حيث
يمكنك التحدث إلى جهاز كمبيوتر
ويمكنك  اجعلها تفعل شيئًا من أجلك
وأعتقد أن الحدود الكبيرة التالية هي الرؤية
بدلاً من الاضطرار إلى وصف كل شيء
بالكلمات ، يمكنك فقط إظهار ما
تريده ويقول الكثير من الأشخاص الذين يستخدمون
Pinterest أن ما
يحبونه هو أنهم لا يفعلون ذلك.  لا أعرف كيف يصفون
كلمات الإلهام الخاصة بهم لكنهم يعرفون
ماذا عندما يرونها وأنا بينتيريست
إذا تمكنوا من العثور عليها ، فيمكننا أن نظهر
لهم الأشياء ذات الصلة ويمكنهم أن
يوسعوا الأفق نوعًا ما.
لقد كان هناك الكثير ، وبالتالي فإن المستقبل
يستثمر في الذكاء الاصطناعي
الذي سيمكن Pinterest من
أن تكون لوحة المفاتيح المرئية تلك ، وكيف ستلعب هنا بالضبط
وما هي الأشياء التي تعرفها وهل هناك أشياء أخلاقية
تفكر فيها  في نفس الوقت
التحدي هو أنك تريد أن تظهر لك
الأشياء التي نعتقد
أنك ستستمتع بها ولكننا لا نريد أن نجعلها
ضيقة جدًا بالنسبة لك ، لذلك إذا قمت بتثبيت وصفات الدجاج
بالأمس ، فإننا لا نريد ذلك إلى
الأبد  نعرض لك وصفات الدجاج ، وبالتالي فإن
أحد المجالات التي نطبق عليها الكثير من
التعلم الآلي والذكاء هو كيف
نعرض لك الشيء الصحيح في
الوقت المناسب ومتى حان الوقت
لتوسيع آفاقك وإظهار
شيء قد لا يمكنك أبدًا.  التي رأيناها
قبل الثانية هي رؤية الكمبيوتر التي
استثمرناها لفهم نوع ما
بداخل الصور حتى تتمكن من العثور على الأشياء
التي لها نفس النمط الجمالي
حتى لو لم تتمكن من وصفها كما لو كان من
البديهي حقًا الدخول إلى متجر  ا
تحدث إلى شخص ما في المتجر وأقول مرحبًا
، أريد شيئًا
يبدو كهذا يجعلني أشعر بهذا ، لكن
من الصعب جدًا ترجمته إلى
تجربة تسوق عبر الإنترنت اليوم
وأعتقد أن Pinterest في طريق جيد
لتحقيق ذلك  تجربة
يمكن الوصول إليها عبر الإنترنت بشكل أكبر